alors au début vous appelez le groupe
Texas en hommage au film de vimander's
Paris Texas et quand vous allez aux
États-Unis et que vous voyez le Texas
vous dites on a fait une grosse connerie
quand même
bonsoir
vous parlez vous parlez français vous
préférez qu'on parle anglais alors pour
parler anglais on a quelqu'un
[Musique]
Belinda oui bonsoir très bien et vous
êtes à l'antenne Belinda décrivez-vous
physiquement ah mais vous me posez sur
la même question il va falloir descendre
maintenant de la tête j'ai un coup pas
mal
non je crois que ce sera pour la
prochaine fois faut garder un petit
système quand même vous aviez promis la
poitrine ce soir
mais je vous ai déjà dit que vous êtes
immensation sexuelle donc vous
découvrirez un temps
alors Charlie non on se connaît depuis
longtemps parce qu'en fait la première
télé du groupe Texas en France c'était
dans une émission qui s'appelait
lunettes noires pour nuit blanche
ça n'aurajunit pas alors à l'époque
j'avais complètement flashé sur vous qui
m'aviez jeté un regard mais terrible
quoi ça m'avait glacé j'ai dit j'ai
aucune chance alors en fait vous parlez
bien français mais seulement quand vous
êtes bourré c'est ça quand vous êtes
vous
très bon français quand je suis saoule
elle parle bien parce qu'elle s'en fout
des fautes de français l'alphabet
sous comme un Polonais alors faut dire
que vous avez une grand-mère française
et votre père a vécu 36 ans à Bordeaux
c'est beaucoup de familles à Bordeaux et
puis quand vous avez eu il y a quelques
années des problèmes de carrière vous
êtes venus vous réfugier à Paris auprès
d'une styliste qui s'appelle Corinne
club Sun donc ça explique que peut-être
tout à l'heure vous me direz quelques
mots en français alors au début vous
étiez pas au début du groupe Texas vous
étiez pas tellement en avant et puis
maintenant vous êtes devenu un petit peu
le porte-parole du groupe parce que vous
dites les autres membres du groupe sont
trop timides pour contredire les
journalistes
je suis un peu plus âgé maintenant ça
fait 15 ans que je fais ça
au début
j'étais
après protectrice
et j'étais un petit peu la femme dans le
monde de la musique et je voulais qu'on
nous voit quand même groupe et je
protège beaucoup ce groupe et une fois
qu'on a établi ceci ça a été beaucoup
plus facile pour les gens de m'accepter
vous pensez que vous ferez une carrière
solo un jour
ça ne m'intéresse pas vraiment
je suis pas en fermant quelqu'un qui s'y
prend la performance si la musique quand
elle dit
de James Bond et toi tu nous fais la
fontaine je boirai pas de porno je te le
dis Belinda c'est un peu voilà quoi
merci Thierry
j'apprends mon métier avec vous
alors
votre père était capitaine dans la
marine marchande votre mère était
infirmière
ma mère n'a jamais été infirmière
des vitrines et le travail dans la mode
problème donc vous allez voir donc vous
êtes né à glace Go votre père était
capitaine dans la marine marchande votre
mère travaille dans la mode et s'occuper
des vitrines
musiciens donc beaucoup d'instruments à
la maison beaucoup de disent vos parents
nous ont fait cadeau de leur collection
de disques et après le lycée vous êtes
coiffeuse
au début des années 80 quand j'ai quitté
l'école et ils m'ont dit est-ce que ça
t'intéresserait d'être coiffeuse pour
garder un peu d'argent pour que je
puisse payer mon loyer
Joe Strummer de clash à la télévision
non
et c'est ce que je voulais faire et je
n'ai jamais rêvé d'être musicien quand
j'étais enfant je pensais que je serai
une artiste
et je suis tombé dans la musique si je
puis dire à 17 ans
c'est ça c'est ça et vous avez fait le
Texas ensemble alors au début vous
appelez le groupe Texas en hommage au
film de vimanders Paris Texas et quand
vous allez aux États-Unis et que vous
voyez le Texas vous dites on a fait une
grosse connerie quand même
des déceptions quand on était Réauté que
ça
j'étais vraiment choquée parce que
c'était rien de ce que nous imaginiez
et en fait
un gros succès votre premier succès
c'est ça
ça marche bien et après les deux albums
suivants sont quand même des bides
par la suite
beaucoup
vendu en français c'est ce qui nous a
permis de garder
la carrière cette carrière et c'est
grâce à l'achat des Français donc d'un
seul coup vous étiez un peu les rois du
monde et puis d'un seul coup vous êtes
devenu un peu un peu plus looser d'une
certaine façon il y a eu des rumeurs de
séparation à ce moment-là du groupe
Texas
vont se séparer
quand on ne voit pas mais faisons
beaucoup de travail dans le studio on
est en train de décrire des chansons et
je vivais toujours à Paris et je voulais
essayer de me recentrer sur moi-même et
j'avais déjà eu du succès et
des gens qui travaillent avec moi
étaient en train d'essayer de justifier
le fait que je devais être une grande
star et c'était pas vraiment mon idée ce
n'est pas mon intérêt je ne voulais pas
s'y être similaire à tout ce showbize et
je suis partie tout simplement alors
quand vous revenez au sommet c'est avec
wait-on blonde 3 millions d'exemplaires
et un nouveau look un peu un peu plus
androgyne c'est qu'en fait vous ce qui
fait votre force s'il vous plaisez aussi
bien aux hommes qu'aux femmes
on va voir tout de suite Clara
évidemment
non mais c'est vrai déjà quand vous
étiez petit de vous refusiez de jouer à
la fille de minauder dur Belinda minodée
être très féministe minaudière
j'aime beaucoup voir les femmes qui
savent ce qu'elles veulent dans la vie
et c'est vraiment le genre de personne
qui m'attire c'est un peu ambigu quand
même ça vous êtes devenu une idole pour
les lesbiennes par exemple
mais
d'être entre femmes qu'elle soit
lesbienne ou pas pour moi c'est
véritablement un grand compliment comme
fait ça ne me dérange pas absolument pas
je pense que
les grands dans la musique
semble être effectivement gay et pour
être sûr de ne rien rater de innarditube
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu